皆様に
あ
謝らなければいけないことがあります
昔ツイッターで卒業論文の
研究テーマが
じゃんけん分
確実に勝つ方法って言ったんですけども日食べ車
ウール2
ああああああ
nan うわあああ
は行っついてすみませんでした
僕も言いたくなかったんですよ無垢も言いたくなかった
う卒業論文を印刷してる時
じゃんけんについて書いたって言ったら面白いんじゃないかなと思ってる
ふざけでツイッターで言ったらうんなんかみんな信じちゃってああ
ああうんみんなすごい立ツイートとかされてああ
じゃんけん研究会と土佐の連絡も来てああ
u 2 u 2 u 2件だけだったし罰んですよ
えっすいませんでした上の人ならスプーンを信じないと思ってなくって嘘ついたんです
けど
残件については書いていますねじゃんけんで家族全員画像をないで
はいというわけで卒業論文は山県ではないことちゃんと書いてましたはず目社長です
今日をもちまして凸行論文の最終発表会が終わりましてやっと卒業論文に関することは
すべて終了でございます受かって本当に慣れちゃったぐらいかなぁも去年げないかなあ
もう去年ぐらいからの動画でずっとなんか卒業論文書かない
んじゃとかね卒業の出し投げとかどうこう言いながら動画とってて星の育つも実家に
帰る暇もなく家で引きこもってずっと卒論を書いてあんとか期限に間に合いてその合間
を縫ってうち6の動画を作ったり東京に行ったりで毛髪めちゃすぎて羽生なんですけど
人生でこんなに忙しい危機感はなかったなと思っています約嬉しかったそう付いてる
けど苦しかったですそれでも
なんとか頑張ってねなんとか無事に付いても作って毎日動画を出そうと思って頑張っ
てるんですけど
論文は一通り終わりましたレポータースタート20何万円くらいかクックを変えたん
ですけど大学生は音ですよ
内容は同校にしろねなんとか一応その辺室もできてちゃんと終わったのでドアでずっと
卒論卒論で言ってたからこれはちゃんと言わなきゃと思って今回曲をとっておりは本当
に
長い期間でしたがなんか色々すごいね卒論頑張ってと思うが頑張ってとか言われて
嬉しかったんですよ本当に応援してくださった皆様ありがとうございました
無事はず3冊を卒業に一歩近づくことができましたないしのテストさえちゃんとクリア
できれば
必要なのでもう一度しで最後の学生生活頑張ろうと思います本当に時間に追われてたぜ
頑張り入り込んで忙しいとか言うとちょっと格好れいいなと思ってるあんまり言いたく
ないんですけど正直めちゃくちゃ時間がなかったよもう何度1日が24時間以上あって
欲しいと願ったことかくらいでもう本当に寝る時間もなくてご飯食べる時間もなかった
時もあって労働操ればさ
とかだったかもしれないですけどでも自分の中ではしたくなくてなんとかかんとかやっ
てきてここまで来れました本当にこんな忙しい中で卒業論文が書けさんがマジで皆様の
おかげでございますもう少し大学生活頑張っていこうと思います
あこのまま終わらないよほどもうあんたら何かけ中で動画になるんで
2月の質問コーナーのコメントはここで母数しようと思いますテスト後には懐かないと
指にこの動画のコメント欄に僕に対する親質問ではありませんご質問でもいいしで
クリスと言いたいこと文句プロポーズ砂糖をなんでお好きなことを書いてください
書かれたコメントから僕が
適当にピックアップして質問コーナーのどうぞを作ろうと思います牡丹の質も高などが
作ってる頃には僕多分もあれなんでゲット終わってるんでを謀りバレた時も付けれもう
動画撮ってると思いますお楽しみに
苦手の中旬ぐらいに質問コーナー動画だと思いますを適当にパパッと種類つの前が打線
で見ない気楽に待ってくださっ質問コーナーコメント書いてくださいという動画でした
口だけでちょっと
テスト勉強もう少しな肌と思いますじゃあないっ
持って行っ
ん
ano ang